ainsi la france fut de près la situation
en afghanistan c'est aussi le cas de la
russie si on en parle justement avec
notre correspondant à moscou funk et on
entonne bonjour alors comment la russie
chez réagit-elle au changement de
pouvoir actuellement à l'oeuvre à kaboul
oui pierre est bien de façon générale la
russie est favorable au dialogue et à la
coopération avec le pouvoir le nouveau
pouvoir qui est en train de se mettre en
place à kaboul mais elle compte bien
observer l'évolution de la situation
avant tout avant toute reconnaissance
officielle de ce nouveau pouvoir une
situation qui au passage tend à se
stabiliser
écoutez
nous suivons de près l'évolution de la
situation en afghanistan après le
transfert du pouvoir dans ce pays aux
mouvements talibans en raison de
l'absence quasi totale de résistance de
la part des forces armées nationales
formé par les états unis et leurs alliés
selon les informations disponibles la
situation à kaboul et en afghanistan
dans son ensemble se stabilise les
talibans ont commencé à rétablir l'ordre
public et on confirmait les garanties de
sécurité des habitants et des missions
diplomatiques étrangères nous appelons
toutes les parties afghane à s'abstenir
de toute violence et à contribuer au
règlement pacifique de la situation à
l'heure actuelle aucune aucune
évacuation de l'ambassadeur russe à
kaboul n'est prévu l'ambassadeur a dit
avoir reçu des garanties sur le fait
qu'un certain nombre d'ambassades au
sein de la capitale afghane un certain
nombre d'ambassades dont celles de
russie ne craignait rien de la part du
nouveau pouvoir en place des précautions
ont bien sûr été prise mais de façon
générale la vie continue de façon quasi
normale au sein de l'ambassade écoutez
nous avons pris l avance un ensemble de
mesures très sérieuses pour renforcer
notre sécurité est à l'heure actuelle il
n'y a pas de menace immédiate pesant sur
notre équipe et nos infrastructures
par conséquent nous continuerons notre
travail ici dans le calme et selon la
procédure établie
l'ambassade russe examine également les
demandes de rapatriement
des ressortissants russes bloqués dans
la capitale afghane l'ambassadeur lui
doit rencontrer ce mardi un représentant
des talibans afin de discuter du
dispositif de sécurité concernant
l'ambassade de russie et ce sur le long
terme merci antoine claireaux en direct
de moscou